The Joe Rogan Experience I don't think
this is gonna work
oh my God [ __ ] I can't like
I can't see at all I don't know how he's
supposed to see out of that it's a
deadly outfit
I guess I'll just put that on when I
want to say something incriminating
yeah what do you mean well the thought
police
so pull up that article Jamie at the
beginning of this podcast we should
probably go right into this
because apparently
the Department of Homeland Security
and Twitter yeah we're working together
are we on yeah I don't hear there we go
the Department of Homeland Security
was uh they they had a plan to police
information and they were working with
Twitter
in some fashion
like look at this quietly broadening its
effort to curve speech it considers
dangerous yeah what does that mean I
don't know an investigation by The
Intercept has found years of internal
DHS memos emails and documents obtained
via leaks and an ongoing Lobster
and an ongoing lawsuit as well as public
documents illustrate the expansive
effort by the agency to influence the
tech platforms
the work much of which remains unknown
to the American public
came into Clearview earlier this year
when DHS announced a new disinformation
governance board good Lord a panel
designed to police misinformation false
information spread unintentionally
disinformation false information spread
internally
and intentionally excuse me and Mal
information factual information shared
typically out of context with harmful
intent
Mal information is a weird one Mal
information yeah because it's factual
but it's shared typically out of context
with harmful intent that's where you're
like you look you don't understand why
we mowed down those reporters with the
chopper it's out of context you can't
just show the video while the board was
widely ridiculed immediately scaled back
and then shut down within a few months
other initiatives are underway as DHS
pivots to monitoring social media now
that its original mandate the war on
terror has been wound down so that's
been wound down
apparently
platforms have got to get comfortable
with government it's really interesting
how hesitant they remain Microsoft
executive Matt Masterson former DHS
official texted Jen easterly look at
that platforms have got to get
comfortable with government
oh what does that mean I don't know Tim
Poole sent me this this morning I didn't
get a chance to I was in the gym look
you got to get comfortable with
government yeah that's what I've been
saying just get comfortable yeah why
aren't you comfortable cozy up put on
some sweatpants cozy up
wow that's creepy
I mean I guess we all kind of suspected
it though right it's not like anybody
that's is that a shocker what would
would uh Tim Poole said is that Twitter
was working with them
that uh they I guess they weren't being
honest about it they were working with
them what were you tell me that the the
Jimmy Kimmel tweeted something and tried
to delete it yeah it looks like
I could be wrong about this but camo was
pissed at musk why for buying Twitter
what does he care what is he mad about
so basically like
a lot of people seem to be really upset
with Elon for buying Twitter because
Elon is saying that he's not going to
censor Twitter anymore he's gonna like
let you know all the band people are
gonna get back on apparently you know
it's like they're trying to figure it
out how to do it and so this has upset a
lot of people who were happy with the
idea that it was being like hyper
moderated in a way I think that fits in
with their politics yeah that was the
idea so it's like so like their team was
in control for a second and now somebody
you know what it reminds me of
it's like when a new Booker shows up in
a comedy club
they're talking [ __ ] it's like scary
it has been interesting over the years
to watch you Blossom from the electric
car guy into a fully formed piece of
[ __ ] wow and look see it says this tweet
was deleted by the Tweet author learn
more he was replying to a tweet that
Elon tweeted and what was the twilon
deleted which I thought that was a tweet
where it's this uh it's like the Santa
Monica Observer or something like that
was tweeting something about the Paul
Pelosi attack and that Santa Monica
Observer has been known to tweet things
that are aren't that aren't correct or
at least has or not tweet publish things
that aren't correct at least has in one
instance that they were citing something
about Hillary Clinton
I don't know but you know he I think
what Elon tweeted was there's a tiny
chance that we might not be getting the
full story and then he tweeted that
story
yeah this is the idea that maybe Paul
Pelosi knew this guy because people have
been trying to pin that guy and say that
he was a right-wing Maga guy but didn't
he live in like some [ __ ] hippie
Collective and he made like hemp jewelry
he did woo to cube pipeline
he went woo to queue so like he
apparently had some kind of uh blog or
something I think he started off woo
super hippie
Ayahuasca mystical and then gradually
kind of devolved into Q
Anon Twitter's Twitter's fact checking
the president United States is incorrect
facts right which is crazy that that's
happening well this is the Emperor wears
no clothes yes that's the Fable right
like these naked dudes going around
everybody's scared of them so they're
like beautiful robes yes and then some
kid is like he's naked look he's
obviously naked and then another
person's like oh yeah you're right he is
it's like that is the pot that is the
like I guess the hope of the internet is
that truth
comes out and it destabilizes bad power
struck bad structures exactly you want
to you want to throw a monkey wrench
into [ __ ] that doesn't work so that it
like stops working and you rebuild
instead of patching up old wobbly things
that are like smokes coming out gears
are flying off and you're supposed to
pretend like it's working right that's
where it gets creepy it's like you know
if the if if the machine that is failing
starts telling tech companies or whoever
like what is real and what isn't then a
broken machine is then like articulating
truth which then so if someone starts
telling the truth never wears no clothes
and then like Twitter throws up
underneath like this is potential
misinformation
or whatever that's why this Department
of Homeland Security thing is so creepy
because that would be the same people
the same people that are telling you
things that are factually inaccurate or
that are getting fact checked on Twitter
would be the very people that would get
to dictate what is Mal information yeah
like Mal information was the craziest
one like everybody thinks you shouldn't
be able to say things that aren't true
right or if you do you must correct them
like are you are you telling the truth
are you manipulating with lies right he
can't manipulate with lies so
if maybe you said something and you
thought it was true let's correct that
yeah but if you just keep doing that
over and over and over again you never
admit that and then you're the one who
gets to dictate what's Mal information
right it's like the death throws of a
Dying system and it's reaching out and
it's acting and behaving the way it used
to be able to behave when it had Total
Access to what gets in what what people
get informed about or not right it had
complete control of that at one point in
time well it's massive I mean we're
talking about how many offices are
filled with people working for the
government right now like how many if
you put them in a in a building like
would the building go all the way to the
Moon would it be like a high-rise
probably the moon would be covered with
Government Office Buildings but like
it's it's massive and then it's so huge
that you know just people get put into
departments and some and some of the
people that get put in the Departments
are good smart people and some of the
people that get put in the Departments
they suck right like everything in all
walks of life yeah right that's all it
takes so you get one like everybody's
had a shitty manager you get one shitty
manager and some job where like he's
he's got a little more power than he's
supposed to have and then he's probably
got people around him are like this is a
bad idea and he's like well you're fired
and then people come in who are like
this is a really good idea he's like
you're a genius if you think this is a
good idea because it is then you have
this like terrible geometry of like
where the contagion happens where this
one [ __ ] like starts getting
surrounded by concentric circles of
[ __ ] and then those people have so
much power and
um and that's I think what's going on
with it is it's just like there's just
too many people running things and of
those people there's got to be some that
are great I know there is and there's
some that are just abject monstrous
power hungry coked up [ __ ] and I
think that's when you start seeing [ __ ]
like that it's clearly a sign of I mean
again maybe I'm being naive but I'd like
to imagine that that's coming from like
a few [ __ ] that's not coming from
the totality of the US government all of
it it's just coming from like what a
thousand [ __ ] but then there's also
the real problem of actual
misinformation that's being spread by
bad parties right like we know that we
know that there's misinformation that
gets spread by bad governments by like
our enemies like we know that there's a
whole industry yeah like these Russian
troll Farms sure you know we've talked
about this before but
in on Facebook 19 of the top 20
Christian sites were being run by
Russian troll Farms yeah I remember you
saying that you know how nuts that is
hooked up that means they're like
they're like some conversations that are
insane that don't make any sense like
how is this how is this a conversation
well it might not be
it might be right we're getting
manipulated it might be there's a bunch
of people and then the problem with
people we were talking about before that
we have this natural inclination to
follow leaders we do that online too man
and it's just like some really good
tweets that point in a certain direction
people will start agreeing with it right
people are easily the idea that
manipulation only applies to like verbal
or or written in a statement No it
[ __ ] applies to tweets too you can
manipulate people dude I get manipulated
all the [ __ ] time are you kidding me
I'm like always getting caught up in
[ __ ] online I like go through like
phases of like yeah oh my God I I pinned
you in between teams or I'll get caught
up in some like deep crazy conspiracy I
like I get like I it's a very potent by
the way I'm not saying it's potent
because I get manipulated easily but
it's a potent drug yes the internet's a
potent drug there's all kinds of
operators it's not just Russian troll
forms it's this accordions it's just
basic like trolls who are bored it's who
knows what probably some cult will never
know about just some weird cult on an
island somewhere with some nefarious
purpose that's like trying to put some
certain information on the Internet it's
a ocean of Madness and maybe like the
the the the
horrible idea is okay we can control the
ocean of Madness that's what we're gonna
do because some of these people are are
other states trying to cause Discord in
our society that could lead to a Civil
War the collapse of the United States
we've got to do something about this
call up Twitter listen it's a problem
you gotta let us tell you what's real
and what's not real and at first maybe
that's great it's like look this is 100
coming from Russian trolls this this
whatever this is this is Russian AI
Trolls but then all of a sudden the
president calls that department is like
hey is there any way that you can also
start applying that to uh people who say
that I seem like I'm kind of out of it
you know what I mean and then
[Laughter]